The Sun’s just a boring old glowing ball
in the sky, right?
So wrong.
Hello all, Amy here bringing you some sunlight
on DNews.
Or at least, knowledge of it.
Recently, NASA’s Solar Dynamics Observatory
took its 100 millionth observation of the
Sun and to celebrate, the mission team released
a gallery of some of their favourite solar
images, and most of them don’t really look
like the Sun we’re used to seeing.
Why is that?
So first off, it sort of goes without saying
that you should NEVER look directly at the
Sun because it will seriously damage your
eyes.
Always use eclipse glasses or special filters
on a telescope or binoculars.
So if someone were to ask you what colour
the Sun is, you would say yellow, right?
Well, the Sun looks yellow because of our
atmosphere.
If you could look at the Sun in space, it
would be a white ball.
But it doesn’t look like a boring old white
ball in these pictures from SDO you say?
That’s because SDO can see far more than
our eyes can.
The spacecraft has three instruments: the
Helioseismic and Magnetic Imager measures
the ripples and the magnetic field on the
visible surface of the Sun; the Atmospheric
Imaging Assembly designed to measure the Sun’s
atmosphere; and the Extreme Ultraviolet Variablity
Experiment tracks the extreme ultraviolet
rays the Sun sends our way.
Not only do all these instruments look for
different things, they look in different wavelengths
of light.
We see in visible light, which is a tiny part
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
As lightwaves get longer you get into infrared
light, microwaves, and radio waves.
On the long end, you get ultraviolet, x-rays,
and gamma rays.
So each instrument on SDO sees in various
wavelengths.
But that’s not all.
Since it launched on February 11, 2010, SDO
has captured some incredible occurrences up
close and in varying wavelengths, like coronal
mass ejections which are massive bursts of
solar wind and magnetic fields rising above
the corona.
And when you take all these observations and
put them together, adding the x-ray observations
of coronal activity with infrared and x-ray
data, you get these amazing, exciting pictures
that show just how dynamic our Sun really
is!
So, will you look (indirectly of course) at
the Sun differently now?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.